this is a production of Cornell
University
okay so I'll start right in I'm going to
keep this my talk to actually about 30
minutes because we have some new farmer
videos talking about climate change I'm
going to reveal one of them to you today
at the end of my talk so I'm going to
save the 10 to 15 minutes at the end of
my talk to flip to a video so instead of
just hearing from me you can also hear
from some farmers so I want to point out
a couple websites here if you haven't
seen the climate change cornell.edu
website i urge you to go there and
subscribe to it it gives you
announcements of things that are
happening a lot of stuff about for
students courses research going on on
campus and the home website has lots of
interesting features on what's what's in
the news about climate etc and then the
second website here the climate
Institute cal cornell edu that's our new
Cornell Institute for climate change and
agriculture website which has a lot of
cool stuff related particularly to my
topic today today I'm going to focus
mostly for this group I'm going to focus
mostly on the issues associated with the
northeastern US but I do have a few
slides on the global story and I will be
giving a seminar next semester in
February in the seat pad seminar series
to get more into this but I thought we
should start with the bigger picture so
the challenge we face regardless of
climate change whether or not we had
climate change is we're going to by 2050
we're going to need sixty percent more
food and that's going to have to
reproduce for an expanded population
also changing diets that is changing the
the demands on resources and impacts on
the environment as people for example
increase meat consumption in certain
developing parts of the world that
increases the impacts on the environment
and resources etc so we need a lot more
food that's going to be on you know a
limited land and water resources 75% of
that increase in food is going to have
to come from producing more food from
the same amount of land and already
about seventy percent of the potential
for irrigation has been exhausted many
experts feel
the globe now climate change does great
greatly exacerbates this challenge
because we add to that new problems with
heat stress in some regions changing
pest dynamics flooding and drought as
i'll go into today more detail and the
adaptation capacity to climate change is
you know very unequal there's financial
barriers in many parts of the world
technological and also perception
barriers about climate change this slide
just illustrates the the added challenge
of climate change with regards to water
as I said even without climate change
our water resources are limited in terms
of trying to meet that future goal by
2050 of feeding the world's population
is hopefully we stabilize around 2050 it
may be 9 billion or so this is showing
climate change projections of parts of
the world in the orange where we're
actually expecting less rainfall in the
future the climate models are projecting
blue areas indicates slight increases
the white areas a little change and so
this course greatly adds to the problem
because even in those areas such as if
you look at where New York is where
maybe there's little change in annual
rainfall predicted for the future the
water demand is going to increase with
longer growing seasons with increasing
temperatures the crop evapotranspiration
and vegetate natural vegetation is
potentially t is going to be going up so
unless you have an increase in rainfall
to keep up with the increase in water
demand there's challenges for more
droughts and of course in these areas in
orange we're on top of that you're not
seeing the same amount of rainfall that
actually reductions the challenge is big
indeed so here's the story for the
Northeast and in kind of a nutshell
looking at the range of climate models
and their future predictions on the
left-hand side for annual temperature
and on the right for rainfall and of
course there's you know error bars
around both of these with the different
models and scenarios and the error bars
are bigger for rainfall it's harder for
the climate
to predict rainfall but if you look at
the gray the gray region it shows kind
of the the most likely scenario and what
you'll see is that for our region what's
projected is like the rest of the world
pretty substantial increases in
temperature rainfall annual rainfall
possibly staying about roughly the same
and what does that mean for us it means
increased drought for those reasons I
just mentioned longer growing season
farmers will be moving to longer growing
season varieties higher temperatures
will increase crop demand so the need
for irrigation particularly for
high-value crops will be dramatically
increased and even for things like our
grain corn that's so important to our
dairy industry could be challenging that
more frequent summer droughts but on the
positive side we don't have we're not
living in an area where rainfall is
predicted to be dramatically decreasing
like in the southwestern US because that
would be even of course much worse so
you could look at this optimistically or
pessimistically that optimistic view of
this is we will have water the negative
view is we still have more summer
drought risk than farmers have seen
before but not the kind of risk of
things like the Finger Lakes drying up
or something dramatic like that of
course this longer growing season thing
is an opportunity for this region opens
up the palette to new types of crops we
might grow and already we see farmers
exploring new crops new markets we've
already had this is the observed
increase and the models all predict of
course this thing this trend continuing
so already seeing longer growing season
length we are seeing already farmers
exploring longer growing season
varieties to take advantage of this so
that's in fact a positive feature
however we have to remember that the
frost free period is not all that
determines the growing season length
we've had for example corn farmers in
the state that are exploring longer
growing season corn varieties because
those are out in the field longer they
produce more than the short growing
season varieties that they've
historically used but what they have
found is that in some years well we have
may have record-breaking frost free
periods they can't get into plant until
late june because it's so darn wet out
there they can't plant so this just is
you know one of the interesting way to
illustrate that climate change is not
just about global warming it's other
issues as well and we're having a very
substantial observed increase in the
frequency of high rainfall events as
I'll talk about later many farmers not
only in the Northeast but in the Midwest
as well are beginning to explore and
actually putting investments into
equipment to when there are windows of
opportunity to get in the field do more
quickly so bigger planters bigger hey
harvesting equipment to get more acres
done more quickly farmers are making
that kind of adaptation because they
feel that the windows are shrinking in
terms of times when they can get field
access so as I mentioned this is again
this is observed data this is not
talking about percent increase in total
rainfall but this is the increase in the
frequency of days in a year when we have
very high rainfall events and you can
see if this is a phenomenon across the
northern hemisphere it has to do with in
a warmer world there's more water vapor
more of the world's water is up in the
air is water vapor as we warm our world
then if you have an upper atmosphere
condensation vent to cause rain there's
more there to come down that's kind of a
basic theoretical reason for this where
to come down comes down is very hard to
predict but you can see in the Northeast
we're the real prize winner in the u.s.
seventy-four percent increase in these
high-level events
another challenge for us in the
Northeast you know an advantage we've
had compared to regions south of here is
we've had less pest and weed pressure
because a lot of things can't survive
our cold winters but of course in a
warming world warmer winters many
innocent insects will benefit abled
overwinter more generations per season
northward expansion of rate of range and
these are just the flea beetle a vector
of Stuart's world an important disease
of sweet corn and corn earworm big
problem with sweet corn both of these
are insects that are coming earlier and
becoming more of a problem in Northeast
with our warmer winters kudzu we modeled
in about ten years ago we modeled that
kudzu would likely be moving north from
the south where it's been a very
terrible base of weed and indeed it is
coming up here as our winters get warmer
so that's a new challenge for us so how
about farmers respond to that probably
more pesticides herbicides etc needed
and that's something where we have to
think about you know the issues the
policy issues of protecting our
waterways from increase chemical inputs
about allowing our farmers to adapt to
climate change so some new challenges
there one thing I certainly learned you
know being involved nuh since the 1990s
is we really have to expect the
unexpected one of the farmer groups that
calls me out more often than others to
talk about climate change is the fruit
growers and it's not about heat stress
it's about more frost damage and freeze
damage that they anecdotally feel that
they are experiencing and indeed we've
had a increased frequency in the past
several years of either mid winter
freeze problems or premature bloom for
example in 2012 most of you know apples
bloomed record-breaking four weeks
earlier than normal a long window of
frost threat and indeed we lost millions
of dollars across the state in
and apple production and we're currently
working we don't have a lot of answers
about this now we're working we have in
my lab group a Apple Bloom model and
trying to look at that in relation to
various climate change scenarios is this
really going to be part and parcel of
climate change or is this simply these
recent events simply part of normal
weather variability and it's the classic
challenge of how do we detect a real
climate change signal against the
background noise of real weather
variability and the jury's still out on
this one so we're still doing research
on this here's this a laundry list of
you know farm level adjustments what
farmers were beginning at this point I
couldn't have said this ten years ago
but at this point i can say i can think
of examples why farmers are actually
doing some other things on this list
right now they might not all have even
recognized that these were climate
change adaptation responses some of them
just their common sense about good
business and realizing they're getting
hit over and over with certain kinds of
problems making certain kinds of
investments to deal with what they would
call unusual weather patterns perhaps
rather than calling a climate change but
certainly in the livestock dairy
industry we see farmers thinking more
carefully about if we're putting up a
new barn making sure it has better
cooling capacity milk production cows
like it really cool and milk production
declines that even temperatures in the
mid-80s at high humidity so a lot of
interest there was recently this past
summer in July I spoke out and was a
very good conference here on dairy and
climate change and there were some
farmers there and quite a few people
very interested in this topic in the
crop solo water management area one of
the big issues like all aspects of
climate change really is diversifying
kind of hedging your bets so instead of
having one planting time having several
planting time so hopefully 11 staggered
planting they do well in a year even
when another
another planting date might be at a
certain stage when there's a certain
kind of let's say mid summer drought or
something that it's vulnerable or you
know mixing it up with varieties and
crops and new crops the one disadvantage
that I had none of these are really
costs to risk free even the simplest
strategy of diversifying of course if
you have a year that's like the good old
years and sort of perfect for the crop
you used to grow but you've now
diversified into a few different crops
to hedge your bets well you might not
make as much money as if you have stayed
with your old crop so so this
diversifying thing does sometimes in a
really quote good year farmers may make
less money on the other hand they are
buffered from effects in bad years I
mentioned the wii disease and insect
pests we really just need to stay on top
of tracking insect we disease pests and
we need ipm more than ever Don mentioned
my interest in soils and Cornell so
health program that's something I'm very
involved with and all I've got a slide
later talking about the importance of so
health in terms of buffering us from
from drought radiation and drainage
systems and this can be even the kind of
thing we're beginning to see some
farmers do is kind of wrap these two
together for example having better
drainage systems to protect from floods
developing ditch systems on a farm to
quickly get a water away from flood
prone areas but then moving that water
into small reservoir so if a month later
they've got a short-term summer drought
they've got some water there to irrigate
with fruit crop frost protection and
then as I mentioned earlier larger scale
farm equipment is it something we read
in ourselves really think of a few years
ago but we see farmers going to this as
a way of covering more acreage faster
because they feel like they've got these
shrinking windows for for field access
that laundry list of things as I
mentioned already you know it's not but
none of them are costs to risk free so
the problem for farmers is you know it's
a really time for me to think about
doing something different and most of
those doing something different things
means some investment in labor money
certain kinds of risks and so this is
the this is kind of where we're at at
Cornell and any other places trying to
support farmer adaptation is providing
support services to farmers to help them
make those decisions that's what the
Cornell Institute for climate change and
AG very much focused on his new tools
for farmers to help them give them the
information to make wise decisions
perhaps in some cases that may be why is
the wait a year or two in other cases it
may be they should have made that change
years ago and it's definitely time to
make the shift this is another trend I
we see happening in terms of helping
farmers cope with climate but it's
really not that much focused on climate
change it's really what we call seasonal
climate forecasting so in addition to
Prime trying to provide farmers with
simply better weather forecasts you know
instead of five days out seven days
twelve days out really provide better
information that gives them a better
idea of what the whole season is going
to look like and 11 certain parts of the
world where we can really do this our
parts of the world which are very
sensitive to these El Nino La Nina
cycles unfortunately the Northeast is
not an area that's particularly
sensitive to those cycles so as you can
see with this map here this is happens
to be a map showing January looking at
the historical record for strong El Nino
years and the white areas are areas
where really there's little change from
normal quote normal in terms of rain
rainfall in January and the green areas
and blue areas are areas whether
substantial increases in rainfall in El
Nino years but you can see if you're a
farmer in Florida or California having
information on whether it's an L need
gives you very good information on
upcoming potential rainfall forecast now
this is only as good as a historical
record they simply do a relationship
between historical El Nino years and
what happened in those years in I've
spent my last sabbatical leave at
University of Florida and because that
area is so sensitive these El Nino
cycles they have it you can actually
there's a really great website to agro
climate website they have there for
farmers you can put where your farm is
and it gives you month-to-month
information on all kinds of issues about
El Nino or La Nina years so once you
know what kind of year were having like
this year happens to be a very strong
island you know year the farmer can look
and see month by month what kind of
deviations from normal temperature and
rainfall they might have so the
challenge for the Northeast is actually
coming up with something like El Nino
but it's got it El Nino doesn't work
that well for us and Toby Alton our
earth an aspheric sciences department
here at Cornell is working very hard at
looking at other things that might be
clues to give our farmers seasonal
forecasts I mean it could be who knows
what you know a warmer summer in Calgary
Canada may mean a wetter spring in the
Northeast and even if it's a black box
thing like that if it has high
probabilities it could be useful to our
farmers universities are all about this
farmers are getting on top of this and
industries also seeing the opportunity I
was out in San Francisco for the
American Geophysical Union conference a
few years ago visited this new company
it was kind of mostly a lot of guys from
google men and women from google really
just good with analyzing data satellite
data and everything developed this thing
called the climate corporation to give
farmers everything that we've got to
bear these days with what's happening
with climate satellite data bring it all
to bear on their farm giving them
information to guide their their their
farm practices focus pretty much on the
Midwest when I was there two three years
ago it was a really cool office you know
typical Google office you know
no no up walls between the offices and
all these young people is really very
exciting place they hadn't yet made any
money Monsanto bought the not for a
billion dollars last year one thing we
worry about our financial barriers of
course well all farmers have access to
some of these new tools equity issues
have the capital strategic information
to death so that's a whole social
science tissue that kind of goes along
with our climate change story and work
and we have a lot of social scientists
at Cornell getting very engaged with us
on this issue and also internationally
as well I was just in Malawi working
with Rachel Besner occur in the
development sociology department here
and working with farmers there on
climate change and a lot of issues for
those small and holder farmers so at the
global issue we also of course have
equity issues there's a whole I'm
focusing a lot on crop production for
the audience today but of course this
whole issues with distribution waste
management and all of that things sort
of thing and a lot of big issues there
to deal with so in my last few slides I
want to talk a little bit about the
other side of the coin which is not
simply coping with climate change
farmers learning to deal with sort of
some inevitable changes in the weather
patterns that they're seeing but also
what can they do to improve energy
efficiency at the same time improve
their bottom line and actually farmers
are all about this in many ways I mean
farmers went to diesel engines decades
ago before climate change was a problem
not because of climate change or because
of the goodness of their heart they felt
like improving energy efficiency but it
saved them money and so farmers are
really excited about renewable energy
opportunities on the farm and very open
to this biofuel crops you know it's a
big complicated controversial issue it
makes a lot of sense from the standpoint
of instead of bringing new carbon from
fossil fuels buried deep in the earth up
to our climate system
and having to deal with that carbon for
a long time to come recycling carbon
through biofuel crops however of course
it makes a big difference how you grow
that crop if you use a lot of fossil
fuels to grow the crop you kind of
spoiled the advantage of it if you're
using food crops you could compete for
food prices and and then where you go to
if you're competing with prime
agricultural land those issues like that
to deal with but from a simply
theoretical standpoint there is some
good sense behind the biofuel crop thing
re coupling animal and crop production
systems I don't know to see when you see
that picture but I see nitrogen carbon
and energy and as you'll well at the
website the farm video you're going to
see today is about adaptation but at our
climate change website we have a similar
farmer video talking about mitigation
and there you'll hear a number of dairy
farmers talking about anaerobic
digesters to deal with manure waste and
get free energy for the farm and also
deal with odor problems on the farm and
things like that it surprises some
people to learn that when you look at
the developed world a place like the
United States in particular and if you
do things on the co2 equivalent basis
the big problem on our farms in terms of
the big contributor of agriculture to
climate change in a place like a u.s. is
not co2 emissions from tractor driving
but nitrous oxide emissions that's
because nitrous oxide is 300 times more
potent on a molecule for molecule basis
than co2 it's released in trace amounts
about 1% of a nitrogen fertilizer put
onto land goes up into the air as
nitrous oxide even if you're using
manures organic sources of nitrogen this
is the case of course if you're using
manures or organic sources you do reduce
your carbon footprint because you're not
you're not paying for the embedded
carbon footprint of the manufacturer of
the nitrogen but still even manure
sources released nitrous oxide so a key
to this story for the developed world
and farming is better nitrogen
management here at Cornell we have this
adapt in tulle many of you may have
heard about Harold on this has been
quite involved with it I've been
involved in some ways to whether based
precision nitrogen management tool been
very successful with corn farmers and
we're beginning to look into expanding
it to other crops as well uses real-time
weather to figure out what the nitrogen
mineralization rate is so that farmers
can account for basically the free
nitrogen due to microbial activity in
the spring and it's now been
commercialized available in 26 States I
mentioned soil health you know I look at
this as both the building soil organic
matter something we're talking to
farmers about for many years for crop
productivity but it's both an adaptation
to climate change in terms of increasing
resilience to drought and flooding high
organic matter means better water
holding capacity and drainage and it's
also carbon in the soil at otherwise
it'd be in the air as co2 now in
developing countries when we talk about
mitigation it's not about nitrogen
fertilizer they don't use a lot of
nitrogen fertilizer a lot of it has to
do with moving plot to plot quickly
depleting soul resources and doing a lot
of slash and burn agriculture
deforestation to feed a growing
population and it's a significant part
of global co2 emissions our social of
deforestation and a lot of that
deforestation is associated with
agriculture so in the developed
developing world a lot of the emphasis
is really on improving maintaining high
quality soils so this process can be
slowed in maximizing production from my
land just mention a one project i'm
involved with in zambia there's a paper
and preceding national academy of
sciences that goes into details it's a
co-op of actually about 20,000 small
land holder farmers very poor farmers
and some years ago they got involved in
working together on developing soil
building processes to help their
productivity but we've also been working
with them on entering carbon markets to
get credit for that they have been
growing these that tree down there in
the middle in the center is a fader BIA
albida tree and nitrogen fixing tree
they planted 700,000 of those into
dropping those in their land area for
getting basically nitrogen for their
crops but those trees also store carbon
so it's a kind of a win-win scenario
they've done a great job of marketing
their products they have a website
called it's wild org if you want to
check it out and they market their own
peanut butter for example and I'm really
doing cool things and this gets into you
know what we eat and so deciding to buy
from a place like fat is a consumer
choice and I just wanted to mention
since we I did mention food systems and
we all of us as consumers affect farmer
choices and the sustainability in carbon
footprint of Agriculture so we can think
more about what we're eating just a
couple more slides then I'll show the
farmer video wanted to kind of put these
things together and say that you know
sustainable development sustainable AG
development and climate changes are
linked in many ways and kind of two big
ways both on the mitigation and in the
adaptation end so using sustainable
farming practices can help reduce
greenhouse gases sequester carbon and it
buffers the farmer from climate change
in terms of I mentioned earlier drought
and flooding water holding capacity and
drainage of soils when I've talked to
farmers almost no matter well no matter
where I've been in the world there are
some common ground and some places to
enter the conversation of course in this
country not so much in other places I go
to but in this country as we all know
the climate change issues become very
politicized but I've never met a farmer
here or anywhere there's not concerned
about extreme weather events and
uncertainty about the weather and that's
the way we begin the conversation every
farmer is concerned about that and as
you'll see in our farmer video will show
you in a second some of them are a
little reticent to use the phrase
climate change but they're all concerned
about those issues and doing things to
deal with them bummers have the same
problem we all do including climate
scientist detecting you know a real
climate change trend that they should
invest in against the noise of weather
variability and that's part of the job
of climate scientists that place like
Cornell help them figure that out and
then on the mitigation end I mean
farmers are all concerned about energy
that all interested in future energy
renewables and that kind of thing
however they're also very concerned
about climate change policies so this is
something where we have to consider
where they're coming from many farmers
are more afraid of the policy reaction
to climate change and climate change per
se they think of like things like carbon
tax is affecting their transportation
costs etc so we have to keep all of that
in mind and with that I want to turn it
over to the video and hopefully we can
get this going I can just click on this
so now you're there's a little bit of me
doing a little bit of intro to this but
you'll see here from a few different
farmers talking about adaptation and
then we'll have some time for questions
it should take about 12 minutes
the weather is definitely becoming more
erratic and more extreme than what I've
had been in the past I have that
tendency as others do that have lived a
long time in the same place to say well
the winters aren't as cold we're not
getting as much snow certainly it's been
a surprise over the last few years how
much earlier the seasons have become in
general and I would say that it actually
does seem like the season gets hotter
faster we're here at one of cornell's
apple orchard research sites new york is
well known for the quality of its apples
were usually second or third in the US
and apple production and we got there by
farmers from over many years really
working with Cornell researchers to come
up with best management practices but of
course now we're facing like farmers
everywhere new challenges challenges
associated with climate change for
example I never expected when I got into
this climate change research realm back
in the 1990's that one of the most
important things that would come up with
regards to the fruit crop growers is
actually cold and frost damage in a
warming world the reason for that is
that these plants can sometimes be
tricked into blooming earlier with a
warming winter and we had known from
looking at historical records that the
apples were blooming a few days earlier
than they used to but in 2012 there was
a real record breaker the apples in the
state bloom about four weeks earlier
than normal never never observed before
and of course this put them into a
really long period of frost risk and
sure enough we lost close to half the
crop in much of the state millions of
dollars of damage so to deal with this
sort of thing we have to think about
things like frost risk warning systems
for farmers farmers may have to consider
misting systems or wind machines for
frost protection and our apple breeders
may have to think about coming up with
genetic types that don't jump the gun in
terms of early bloom in warm winters so
the experience of adapting to climate
change may be different for each farm
but nevertheless many of the state's
leading agricultural industries which
include dairy grapes apples and first
market produce all face new challenges
new risks and new opportunities when it
comes to climate change in a depth
asian farmers across New York all have a
story to tell I'm Dale sign senior
partner and Stein farms in Leroy we milk
850 cows work almost 3,000 acres of land
today we've had very heavy rain all
morning they got flood watches up all
over we've seen years where a drought
we're on the gravel ground you get
almost no yield we actually had two
years in a row two thousand eleven and
two thousand twelve or to dry here so
all our forages were lower production we
feed 75 tonne of feet a day so about
four tractor-trailer loads of the--
today we ended up by the end of 2012
running out of our surplus forage we
used all that up we end up on those
years buying more grain which increases
our pasta production and lowers to
profit down but we're harvesting 1500 to
2000 ton of triticale every May that if
I didn't have that's extra on the same
ground I didn't have that we would have
been in a lot worse place than we were
without it the forage inventory
shortages that we've had from extreme
weather conditions in recent years is I
is really just the sign of things to
come unfortunately farmers have to deal
with a change in climate each and every
day and so in extension we really try to
help farmers manage their risk and
growing a triticale forage crop or
another small grain for forage can
really give another opportunity to
protect their resources over the winter
because they're more vulnerable to
extreme precipitation events and losing
that soil we can protect the soil notice
the fibrous root system this is why this
crop can hold soils just see how much
soil even in this couple inches of roots
that this is holding onto my standpoint
from what I've seen on this farm
tradução works very well for us and the
palatability is phenomenal a cow's love
it so this is an awesome combination of
a profitable crop that protects the
environment baffles me why more farmers
aren't using Marchetta Cal just baffles
me
I'm Paul King I do most of the vineyard
management and most of the winemaking
and all of the distilling here at six
mile creek vineyard and I've been here
for almost 25 years if we talk about
climate change longer growing season and
a little hotter weather will ripen the
fruit more dependably there are some
varieties and I give you two or three
examples Pinot Noirs a little fussy
Merlot for sure Cabernet Sauvignon and
to a lesser degree Chardonnay I think
these are varieties that will benefit
the best management option for any
individual vineyard to deal with
increasingly varying weather if we talk
about climate change would be to think
carefully about the varieties that
they're growing that's really the
biggest management strategy because
everything else you're doing is then a
little bit of sort of a stopgap wind
turbines help in only very specific
weather conditions we're very calm
conditions are set up and there's a deep
gradient between the temperatures at the
surface in just a few hundred feet in
the air and mixing up that layer can
help a lot but they're pretty specific
weather conditions and it's a pretty
costly investment you need to grow the
varieties that you can grow well and
that's what you need to do that is
especially true at six mile creek but
it's also true for any of the other
vineyards last winter was a particularly
cold one and its really interesting i
think the minimum low temperature in
ithaca is still probably minus 23
degrees fahrenheit or so we didn't
really approach that but what we did see
here were lots of excursions to minus
14-15 minus 16 degrees and that is a
very very critical temperature you're
going to get significant blood loss
right around that threshold what is that
going to have on quality and quantity of
wine grapes that are grown in the region
and certainly at six mile creek vineyard
we have lost most of the reasoning the
proof that we had here as compared with
our save all a hybrid where we have
virtually a full problem
there is a lack of name recognition of
some of these hybrids save all Blanc
that sounds a lot like Samuel block but
but is it a seven young black and well
it's it's not a seven young blonde it's
a completely different variety it's my
personal favorite I get six ton per acre
even here it's disease resistant it's
one of the first great varieties to
ripen it's a beautiful grape variety
it's just relatively unknown but I think
the people that I know that most enjoy
wine really like trying new wines so
there's a huge huge outlet out there for
exploring some of new hybrids they're
great varieties it's one of the Finger
Lakes Forte's in the long run that's
gonna serve to help us I'm rod Pharaoh
one of the owners and operators of
lamont fruit farm in water plot New York
we operate about 500 acres of apples
straw all kinds of rage about 29
different ones the major varieties would
be Empire honeycrisp gala Fugees sweet
tangos we've certainly moved our bloom
time forward probably at least five to
seven days and some years a lot more
than that how much of this we can
attribute to climate change is still a
little bit debatable to me personally
but there's certainly a sense that
things are changing here and there that
the climate is getting a little more
unpredictable and the risk of early
season and early bloom seems to be
greater and greater every year the
chances of a warm spell in March an
extended warm spell seem to be much
larger now than they were ten years ago
I would say in general I farms
definitely vulnerable to extreme weather
events it always has been we're at the
mercy of Mother Nature no matter what we
do the question is has the frequency
increased and the risk certainly say
they've been a lot of extreme instances
of weather over the last thirty plus
years here we've had a number of very
large hail storms but certainly the
frequency of that
has been greater since 1998 one of the
things that drives what you do in terms
of risk management is the profitability
of your business and a profitable
business can afford to do things to
mitigate risk whether that be invest in
frost machines or try to choose better
orchard sites or add overhead cooling or
overhead irrigation for us protection
through the 2000s the orchard business
is generally been pretty healthy so I
certainly see an uptick in an investment
in risk management so anywhere we have
reasonable sites or good orchard sites
we've survived any frost that we've ever
had including 2012 and we look at it as
a company strategy that investing in the
highest possible fruit sites or orchard
sites has just as bigger if not greater
economic impact and then trying to
mitigate a site that's going to be at
risk in years when it's cold certainly
multi parallel insurance can help in
years of distinct disaster and actually
make years that could be very very bad
for you actually is that you could not
necessarily thrive in but you can at
least survive through so we're big
believers in that the strategies that
are being used at the moment to lower
your risk are definitely trying to try
to preserve the economic viability of
fruit farms and businesses in general in
western New York not all climate change
is negative so increasing the number of
heat units per season has a positive
impact on what we can do for fruit size
potential yield and return bloom tree
health so there's always gains and
balances with with anything We certainly
have a little bit higher risk that we
also possibly have a slightly higher
potential in terms of yield and value my
name is Jessica Clark I'm the assistant
farm manager at the BBC farm project and
the poughkeepsie farm project is a
nonprofit that has an educational
mission and also a working CSA for
we are not certified organic but we do
try to use organic practices notice
climate change in terms of the disease
susceptibility of our plants and I've
seen definitely an increase in the
number of different diseases and pests
that can affect us here in the Northeast
certainly when we have very extreme
weather events and certainly when we
have sort of these very strange you know
very either early summers very late
summers or very very late falls so that
it doesn't actually get to freezing
until februari you know I'm sure that
that extends how strong the disease
pressure can be the next year and the
pest pressure and heat stress actually
can be a big factor for a lot of our
brassicas and in general that's
something you deal with as a farmer and
the changing of the seasons spring to
summer brassicas are always going to be
a challenge but they're even more of a
challenge and they're a good indicator
in terms of crops because they do not
like a lot of variability in there
whether they pretty much like the
weather to always be you know relatively
mild not too wet not too dry and pretty
much the same temperature all the time
that's really just not what you get here
so we're already dealing with a change
in climate you know what was it two
years ago when we would have 80 degree
weather and early March and then go
freezing in April crazy things can
happen is this season it's almost like
predicting for unpredictability having
that kind of reinforces the fact that we
you know should have diversified market
areas and also diversified crops you
don't have to be as diversified as the
CSA because certainly that can be a
little bit overboard in some areas but
certainly to rely on one crop is you
know it's like playing a game of dice
like sometimes it's just not going to
come up your turn and if certainly if
you don't have crop insurance and even
if you do have crop insurance you know
it can be a very risky you know game to
play I know people who are in the
orchard business and the in Ulster
County and even their kind of going more
into agro-tourism they're going more
into different crops different specialty
crops just to have something on the side
that they can rely on you know it kind
of makes one as a farmer more bold to
say like oh well we'll just see how
early we can get tomatoes if it's going
to be warmer earlier or we'll see how
late we can have crops you know into the
fall if it doesn't work it doesn't work
but you never know and probably
something else is going to fail in the
meantime I personally like to also make
sure that our organic matter is high in
our soils to begin with so that it has
that humise and organic matter that's
capable of holding water as well as as
much as possible keeping our soil
covered in a cover crop when we can and
then even when we're telling in that
cover crop to try and choose moments
where we're not losing too much soil
certainly we're thinking about carbon
sequestration and being able to lock in
a lot of that carbon into our soil is
partially because it's good for the
earth and partially because it's good
for our plants to have that much you
know to have a high carbon soil you know
you come into the idea of sustainable
farming knowing that you're trying to
not you know we're going the planet and
trying to you know make sure that you're
not um you know you're not messing
things up to that well these are just
some of the experiences and challenges
that farmers throughout the Northeast
are dealing with and adapting to climate
change but we have advantages in this
region to such as being relatively water
rich and with a longer growing season
this could open up new opportunities for
new markets and new crops here at
cornell and Cornell's Institute of
climate change in agriculture we are
poised and ready to take on climate
change challenges and work with our
grower partners stay one step ahead of
the curve and take advantage of any
opportunities that might come our way
you
I thought I'm pretty soon the farmers be
able to do my whole talk and I won't
even need me up here let me get rid of
this I want to hear it again so just
like to thank you for a great you
mentioned that we in the Northeast are
relatively water-rich obviously
California is dealing with a very
different set of circumstances I'd read
a number of pieces about municipality in
California okay
to the ocean and sanitization projects
do you think that that's going to get
viable option for agriculture going
forward in coastal states yeah so well I
big you know that these elements age I
don't I don't follow that literature
really carefully only enough to know
that in place like Israel and listed and
working on that
and that this going drought stress a lot
of parts of the world is increasing the
pressure to move on that technology and
it's getting better getting more
feasible and whether it's you know on my
my initial reaction is probably the
first place that kind of water will go
was from drinking water for humans
because the agriculture needs so much
water and that the cost is high but you
know it is what we are using it for drip
irrigation reversible process we can
minimize the amount of water
so I think that's an area of Technology
that's moving forward whether it can you
know is one of these things like so many
things on my message can we keep pace
with the pace of climate change this
happen
I think if I tradition egghead San Diego
was involved in the desalination plants
costing 1 billion dollar provide seven
for some of the water thank you I'll
hear that San Diego's investing point
Billy but that's kind of the points out
you know we're beginning to see the cost
of adaptation which then puts into
context the cost of doing something to
mitigate
will be the cost to taxpayers be in
future as we continue to just cope with
climate change as opposed to the you
know suppose a tryst slowly
other questions
can you think of any sort of specific
field levels adaptations that you've
seen people experimenting with not just
diversification but changes in the ways
that they manage their fields that may
be artists so well so well in you sorry
that they showed up in the video well in
terms of new ideas i don't know i mean i
had my here i think the things that we
might list which is more attention more
recognition that the whole soul club
thing we were talking about her some
time is also irrelevant to climate
change
in this thing about farmers kind of
tequila by surprises noticing farmers
investing in this big equipment to do
things more quickly on large acreages in
the gulf of windows extreme
yeah i totally think of anything
Allison ticketed you have something
perfect
farmers are constantly innovative in the
pokey like I said that big equipment
stuff is something they surprised me but
things we had we had one of our organic
farmer advisors from an old project who
started ridging his spring crops to keep
them out of the website its baby bears
are risen and then mulching it to try to
keep after the rain stopped to try to
keep the moisture and over the draw be
someone yeah so rigid will keep your
roots out of the wet soil and help the
trainers on the other hand then you do
need to if it gets dry about the dryer
that's an interesting
you're actually to the farmers but you
know we try to include a nap obviously a
range of farmers some kind of Excalibur
shal to small-scale I can't tell you
over you know surprisingly realistic
optimist things are the majority of
farmers willing to change their practice
that even though they're not they don't
need to yet are they really talking
about in a way to prevent more carbon
emissions if they don't get any benefit
from
yeah of course is our farmers willing to
change their practices if they don't get
in
my gut reaction is no they're all about
sending their kids to college you know
eating the families
they want to take a family vacation in
the summer so if it's going to affect
those things not likely to do it for go
to society they don't feel like they're
responsible for that
on the other hand you know I think you
know I have I didn't have my slide
that's kind of climate change they're
just makes good business sense so as all
kinds of things about being one step
ahead of your competitors we've had
people even from like big international
companies like PepsiCo and Sarah and
these are you know liberals groups
coming to talk to us but they're all
about tell us what climate is convenient
parts the world where you stay one step
ahead of our competitors that's all we
need to do to be successful company then
time to change bring on what a day so
farmers are very it would take some
risks and be one step ahead of the
competition so far for example might
start investing thinking more about the
self-help things been hearing about for
a long time when he hears the neighbors
say you know last year was super wet you
know you could get into your field but I
got into my feet the harvest so they
might start thinking about those kind of
things
they're not gonna go too far good cause
well again I'd like to thank gain free
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell edu